dieser fall erschüttert die welt ein
gefährlicher trend im internet und nun
das nächste todesopfer leon braun es 14
jahre alt ist tot der grund auch er hat
mitgemacht einer tik tok challenge ja
das ist ein völlig unsinniges und
lebensgefährliches spiel ein wettbewerb
der film sich jugendliche wie sie sich
so lange wie möglich gegenseitig würden
die luft abdrücken und leon ist jetzt
schon das zweite so junge todesopfer
die black out challenge ein trend auf
tik tok lebensgefährlich schon wieder
stirbt seinetwegen ein kleiner junge der
14 jährige leon braun aus schottland
blackout frei übersetzt bedeutet das so
viel wie das bewusstsein verlieren das
grausame ziel dieser riskanten challenge
die plattform das soziale netzwerk tik
tok teenager selbst kinderfilmen sich
dabei wie sie sich selbst bis zur
ohnmacht würden anschließend laden sie
das video hoch wenn sie überleben
manchmal streamen sie das spiel auf
leben und tod sogar live hoffen auf
klicks und likes
zuletzt stirbt der zwölfjährige archie
peters die aus england er wirkt sich so
heftig dass er für hirntot erklärt wird
vier monate dauert der kampf um sein
leben dann werden die lebenserhaltenden
maßnahmen eingestellt die welt berichtet
nimmt anteil zeigt die verstörenden
bilder aus dem krankenhaus den 14
jährigen leon halten sie offenbar nicht
von der todbringenden challenge ab er
will nur so lange zu drücken bis er
bewusstlos wird seine freunde damit
beeindrucken stattdessen stirbt er vor
ihren augen seine mutter findet ihn kurz
darauf leblos in seinem kinderzimmer und
seine freunde dachten wahrscheinlich es
sei alles sehr witzig aber leon kam
nicht wieder zu sich es ist alles
schrecklich schief gegangen das problem
tik tok spricht vor allem die junge
zielgruppe an das netzwerk ist ab 13
jahren zugelassen in dem alter können
die gefahren solcher challenges aber
nicht unbedingt abgeschätzt werden der
china konzern macht es sich einfach ein
pressesprecher zu den bürger videos
inhalte dieser art sind verboten und
werden gelöscht wenn wir sie finden und
so findet dieser trend ungehindert den
weg in weitere kinderzimmer
eine tik tok challenger hat in
großbritannien einen jungen das leben
gekostet wieder wir sprechen jetzt
darüber mit jakob maske vom
berufsverband der kinder und jugendärzte
schönen guten tag ihnen
dieser gefährlichen trend wie schnell
kann das gehen wie schnell kann es
passieren dass man durch dieses wirken
durch dieses luft abdrücken stirbt was
passiert da irgend körper dass das ganze
so gefährlich macht
es gibt verschiedene mechanismen die
hier in frage kommen die dann zum tode
führen und natürlich kann das enorm
schnell gehen also wenn es eine
bewusstlosigkeit gibt und die argumente
unter umständen aussetzt oder unter
bestimmt auch noch ein herz wieder da
ist dann kann so ein kind wenn ich mich
schnell geholfen wird eben sehr schnell
zum tode kommen und wenn dann keine
sofortigen maßnahmen eingeleitet werden
ist das land letztendlich dann auch
leider das endergebnis und man kann eben
eine wiederbelebung dann nach mehreren
minuten nicht mehr durchführen jetzt ist
es herr maske bei kindern bei jungs in
der pubertät sowieso manchmal ein
bisschen schwierig zu verstehen was sie
umtreibt und warum sie bestimmte sachen
tolle oder attraktiv finden bei der
sache aber nur definitiv also was macht
da von den reiz aus offenbar
bereits macht aus dass man das eben auch
dieser plattform sieht das ist ein trend
ist dass es offenbar lustig dargestellt
wird und fröhlich dargestellt wird genau
hier müssen wir ansetzen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass diese videos eben
nicht verbreitet werden und da kann sich
eben dieser diese plattform nicht
einfach davonstehlen sondern sie muss in
die verantwortung genommen werden was
empfehlen sie eltern auch mit um im
umgang mit ihren teenagern
man hat das gefühl man hat er wenig
einfluss wenig möglichkeiten das ganze
irgendwie em überhaupt zu bemerken
ich glaube das problem ist zunächst mal
dass die meisten eltern niemals denken
würden dass ihre kinder solche spielchen
tun würden und da fing es ja schon an
also wieso soll ich mit meinen kindern
in einer kommunikation treten über dinge
die ich für eigentlich unmöglich halte
und hier müssen wir vielleicht ein
bisschen aufklären aufklärungsarbeit
leisten daneben aufmerksam machen und
ihnen sagen das kann jedem teenager
passieren jeder nutzt in der regel tik
tok lieber übertrieben aber sehr viele
jugendliche nutzen tik tok sehen sich
solche videos an und man muss darum er
darüber sprechen steter tropfen höhlt
den stein man muss die gefahren immer
wieder erklären und unter umständen
erreicht man dann bei seinen eigenen
kindern doch etwas so dass diese dinge
dann eben von diesen kindern nicht
durchgeführt werden jetzt klappt wir uns
nochmal tik tok vor sie haben gerade
schon gesagt das kann diese china
plattform nicht einfach so durchgehen
lassen jetzt ist ja ungewöhnlich dass
sie auf unsere worte hier reagieren wird
die tik tok plattform dieses gigantische
chinesische unternehmen was kann und
muss unsere regierung dann tun also wir
sind ja bei anderen dingen viel viel
strenger jetzt gucken wir da auf diese
plattform und die videos verbreiten sich
rasant im netz also muster unsere
regierung einschreiten können wir das
einfach so laufen lassen mit tik tok
also das ist ja nicht nur das einzige
problem was wir mit dieser plattform
haben wir haben auch andere probleme
also drogen wie unter umständen kein
haar licht oder eben auch harmlos
dargestellt werden auch dieser plattform
wir haben andere probleme
also natürlich muss auch die regierung
hier unter umständen reagieren in den
möglichkeiten die man eben hat bei einem
server der wahrscheinlich in deutschland
steht er also das ist durchaus glaube
ich eine sehr schwierige aufgabe für die
für die regierung aber es ist machbar
und wir sollten sie sensibilisieren
dafür sagt jakob maske vom berufsverband
der kinder und jugendärzte in berlin
vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für dieses
gespräch
[Musik]